it was here in epping forest in essex
that police found a body
in a pond officers investigating the
disappearance
of student richard okoragaya have been
informed
the 19 year old left his family home in
west london
a fortnight ago his family didn't know
why
i don't know what to think at the moment
my feelings is everywhere
i don't know it's scary
he boarded a bus and later took a taxi
to a street in laoton in essex
20 miles away cctv
shows richard who has sickle cell
disease walking towards epping forest
this is his last known sighting
a week after he was last seen friends
near his home in ladbroke grove began
putting up missing posters
appealing for information
the discovery comes five days after
police began searching the forest
which covers an area of six thousand
acres
much of it densely wooded
richard's family have been informed of
the developments no formal
identification has yet taken place but
the metropolitan police say they are
supporting the family
officers remain at the site as their
identification process
continues ashna harinak sky news